[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently off the record we have with us
colleen lionheart oh colleen lionheart
welcome back
right okay is that your real last name
yeah is it the irish a-r-t
or h-a-r-t h-e-a-r-t heart are you
native american then yes 31.2 what so
you're 31 native and 31 chinese
and
what like 34 something else that makes
you look like this quick math
yeah he's good at math
that makes you look like this because
she doesn't look like the other two the
rest is just melt
it's like making a cup of coffee
oh you're 34 dairy oh you heard of milk
you heard of oat milk
so here's the question of the day
question of the day is going to affect
nick a lot i think we should answer
first
if your significant other
asked
for a threesome
could you do it absolutely not ask for a
what a threesome absolutely not
how come i already planned it and it
failed i don't know it just seems like
another person in the room
would just be a total nightmare both guy
or girl yeah i'm out what what makes it
a nightmare
just logistically i think it'd be a
nightmare logistics what is that
somebody getting left out
yeah just the drama of that you got to
get a bigger bed dude you can't be
rocking a twin sized bed i have a queen
bro i have a queen okay okay but what
about looking at him
what about the bed
the bed is fine the bed is fine what's
the logistics behind i don't know it
just seems like look
having to worry about one person
already yeah is a lot not a lot but it's
just like you feel like you all live up
to its potential and you won't be able
to perform
you're so competitive
no it's not that it's not the fact that
i won't be able to perform
can't you frame it as like imagine that
it's just a one-on-two jiu-jitsu fight
yeah see that gets my dick hard dude
that gets me more turned on than
anything
no uh
how do i explain all of his students are
like
everyone watching right now
now that's good for business
no
um no i just i just rather not you know
what i mean because look i don't want
anyone
one biggest thing
no one's touching my lady okay none of
that
even even if it was another lady nah
dude i might get jealous to throw hands
dude you know what i mean i don't get
jealous of girls no no
no but in realistic like
like actually answering this
the right way okay yeah it's just having
another person in the room
that's not my lady stresses me out bro
he's like nah dude because of the type
of intimacy you have it's just weird to
imagine i feel like dude
when we're throwing it down it's good
stuff what if it's just [ __ ]
stuff what if it's a robot
i think
what if you had the dark knight
i think that'll break me and i won't
ever seek intimacy with anybody else
ever i thought he was talking about
batman
great movie that's even better it's
worse than batman or better we don't
know yet
we don't know about joe's gonna do a
product review yeah he's gonna get it
yeah and then he's gonna come back with
his initial thoughts and impressions so
even if even if this meant
if it meant something to your wife if
she's like hey i want to do this you
would just reject it it's not about like
see it's it's it's hard for me to ever
think in a world
that my wife would be like let's have a
threesome
with that guy
i know i know i know i just wanna i just
wanna paint this picture for you okay
you're making a two-wheel
the oedipus complex or don't worry after
we'll get we'll get to you right out
there
don't don't yeah you're next because you
sat on that side yeah what are you guys
talking about we always go
counterclockwise
one time i wished to santa claus i was
like oh
it would be my it would be my dream in
life to be a rotisserie tiffany and then
you said um
but then santa never provided that right
and then and then she's telling you this
and then you're like man
it just sucks because i never achieved
this dream before i got married with you
but i want to do it and then and then
you're like well you know what like is
this what you want baby i give to
i've you heard your voice get that song
because i'm imagining a very special
vulnerable place you know like dude she
wants this man it's like i wanted to be
rotisserie tiffany i
wanted to be in the middle rotating
between two hot men i wanted to be
eiffel tower tiffany chicken dude
absolutely not dude no okay no okay
absolutely not cool no freaking way no
man no woman no anything once again i
really think about the logistics well he
won't even go to a strip club and you
keep saying logistics what the [ __ ] yeah
what does that mean like you don't know
where a dick goes
no obviously i know where the penis in
the vagina goes who gets the 1099 yeah
exactly obviously i know where the penis
goes
what logistics just like
look okay you see temperature do you
feel like you have to kiss someone first
having something what time does she have
to leave yeah
do we do we call you an uber are you
gonna spend the night do i need to buy
both of them yeah none of that is the
during part of it
and that's why yeah stupid
i'm being honest you guys want honesty
this is honesty okay this is not me
deflecting this is like what i really
think about okay i'm a third-party
logistics company i got you covered okay
before and after
now in the middle what are you worried
about in the middle of it okay so
someone's gonna be sitting out
no right someone's gonna be sitting out
oh you got a mouth use it what do you
think it's like a relay race
yeah it's just like
past the baton
right
one person is gonna be sitting now
seeing
no one has to sit out nobody does those
moves in real life dog but no one has to
sit out what are you talking about are
you stacking people on top of each other
because that's what they do in the
movies
i don't
that's crazy that's not that's not real
that's what they did the titanic too
that was the life raft and they needed
to save them i wasn't a threesome the
the yeah dude i have no imagination i
hate you so much that's fine i
appreciate your answer pass it on
anthony yeah anthony i'm bart
okay bart
what would you do
okay now you gotta answer it yeah yeah
yeah do extra dude or extra girl
see at least you got a choice dude or
what do you mean i give you a choice you
don't want to answer i got another
choice doesn't get any choice i got
another choice
this one nick can't have because he's
gonna want this one the most
three dudes
three dudes nina watches wait what wait
what because you want a threesome right
so it's three dudes and nina watches
three dudes oh no can i do that one see
nick wants that one
so nina just wants to watch him do with
reason with two other guys
one of them is nick all right cool she
just immediately leaves the room i will
leave you to it but she wants to see it
right would you do that no no so for you
for you this is a different prompt i
just need to be clear on what the prompt
is okay the same prompt as nick
threesome do you do guy do you do girl
how would it go down what do you think
about it and she's down for she wants it
she wants it more than you she wants it
back asking you if they you absolutely
yes girl what if she goes i want a dude
a filipino dude
dude
a filipino dude
and he's like what a wonderful time
we're having
damn it hey what's the word good image
[Laughter]
she wants that dude
it's the ugliest visual oh that dude is
horrible man
oh damn it that's hard right this game
sucks um dude just say no i think the
answer is no i think well i already know
it's gonna happen when i say no so watch
no
okay
go ahead martha
i pick a girl that's gay dude
that's gay
but i'm kind of with nick a little bit
where i think not logistically
but emotionally and like psychologically
it is a lot to deal with in the room and
before and after because once you
have
multiple players in the tetris game the
tetris isn't the same anymore well i
don't know
what is it like is it like hey in this
threesome i need it to be like love
making you know what i mean that's not
that concept if it's just like a
threesome in terms of like a physical
thing just busting it not really that
much to emotionally get like
it's a massage with your private parts
in your mouth but i'm i'm more worried
about the other person you know what i
mean oh that they're gonna fall in love
with you no no no like i think for dudes
high possibility for dudes it's it's all
a massage right it's like if i go to
massage envy i don't know why they don't
massage my penis either but like i'm
talking about people
were you here for during the
conversation
for chicks
like for geo for example
there's i think guys are more worried
about how the girl will feel it's all
that oxytocin right
that's right
you get what i'm saying yeah but i think
you know i think in the threesome
environment a lot of those things go out
the door even for nina don't make it
real
you guys made it real for me dude [ __ ]
that we're making a room for everybody
okay the stipulation here is that if
your partner wanted it oh right but you
know how sometimes emotionally they
don't know what they want they don't
know what they want okay have you ever
had that conversation with your
significant other yeah and
she said it's so weird no it's not like
we we talked about like the like if
there ever was a potential for threesome
we'd be like absolutely [ __ ] not
uh-huh what about you yeah the classic
story when we were dating if i came i
was like oh maybe once we got like
really really official into it i kind of
tried to bring it up again in a fun
moment see if it were it was like nah i
was like uh dreams see
because i had a situation where i got a
pdf for an engagement ring right shut
the [ __ ] up so set in stone
and then when time comes the pdf changed
and so you know these they've changed
all the time so you don't want to go
with all pdf i like seeing bart across
from me it's nice i can see his facial
experiences
that's what i'm talking about
because i'm cool with all pdfs yeah yeah
you're a pdf guy this guy is murdered by
like a thousand knives like you know
what i mean doesn't it [ __ ] shoot you
in the face it's just like a thousand
nine you just want to hug me what do you
think joe huh
he's like what's the question he's like
it's just a massage
we had to talk about it oh she likes
girls she's gay as hell she's gay but
then i think the but joe's more he wants
a guy but here's the thing like
hooking up
is much different from
now
being too comfortable with another
person in the room like like how often
it happens how many times it happens
then it's like more than it's like then
it's like too personal now that this
third person is no longer a sex object
now we're having a relationship three
ways it's not an experience it's a
relationship now so there's like
rules to the game you know um it can't
be someone who is attracted to me
because then if she's a part of it then
it's more like she wants me
and then she's attracting she's an extra
she's attracted to hannah and i'm the
third person so how do you feel it can't
be a friend you see all the time
audition like how do you filter that out
uh it would have to be
i think craigslist is the best option
yeah probably it would have to be
she finds someone that she's attracted
with
and it's it's and there's no guys
allowed because i'm extremely jealous of
men oh okay no guys can come in i don't
want to see no penis yeah no dicks no
extra dicks none of that [ __ ]
but girls complete opposite she can have
a lesbian side lover i don't give a [ __ ]
just make out all day
eat each other out that's pretty cool
have a great time yeah i think that's
awesome that's like an a plus yeah and i
i don't know why
but for me what if she's like i don't
love you anymore i love her i don't know
too late you know what i mean it's like
[ __ ] i love you so too late whatever but
it but to me it doesn't it doesn't [ __ ]
with my head in the same way for some
reason i don't know why i for me it's
like girls are free game
guys for other but guys just you can't
even have a best guy friend i'll kick
his ass i get jealous of her brother
because they're so close i'm just
kidding
i don't care about that
but um for some reason yeah that's just
a weird
it's a weird uh a thing where i don't
want to have a threesome with a dude but
then a girl will be fine and i don't
even have to [ __ ] the girl that's kind
of a hot take dude me too
yeah
and then the rules would be all dictated
by her if she whatever she's comfortable
with and that's the reason for that is
because for me i'm just
i'm just having enjoyment right but i
don't want to taint what we got and i
don't want
uh an ex a fun little experiment
experiment
[ __ ] up the sacredness that we have so i
want her to always push the bar of what
she's comfortable with not me saying
this is what i want and then her going
like
uh yeah i think i could kind of suffer
with that mm-hmm yeah because then i
start arguing and it's like
subconsciously it's like what are you
really mad about yeah what is it about
exactly and and for me i'll take
whatever i can get because i'm already
happy with this i don't need more but
then if we want to introduce some extra
kinks to it cool but to me it's like
let's bring a vibrator into it that's
how i see a threesome
but then for her
i don't want
her to do something to make me happy but
then it has collateral damage of hurting
her yeah yeah yeah that's no good so so
that seems pretty safe yeah that's kind
of like the rules of engagement for us
but i can't play this and let dudes play
but it sounds like a fun game
also how does how does three player
tetris work yeah yeah yeah what about
you ryan how about you and your girl do
you guys ever talk about that kind of
stuff no we've we never talked about it
i think because they just didn't just
have the same [ __ ] opinion on it and
it's just like what's the opinion just
be weird that's it like it would just be
awkward to even like
i don't know like because i i know we're
the same way like we're both people that
it's hard for us to unsee something yeah
if if you added that in and it would be
like just for one night kind of thing it
would just tomorrow feel weird
and then the next day would feel weird
answer your own [ __ ] question she
wants it what are you gonna do yeah i
couldn't do it because it would just it
would just be too weird for so much time
to come that it's not worth it yeah
maybe i didn't think this through then
because you guys seem very
adamant about something but that's
because like that's only because and
this this relationship i'm in
specifically is that it over time it
took the shape of something that i
really like the exact way it is wow that
that probably wouldn't it wouldn't
survive the same way if that was in it
even just for a day or for like unless
that was like introduced earlier into
your relationship yeah that was like
part of the foundation right then it's
like okay well the perception's
different yeah it's like whatever the
relationship is it fermented into this
form that i'm like no that's it that's
the good leave it leave it leave it
and then like to add extra elements that
don't belong in that that we're both
like and we're very aware of what it is
so it's like oh no that doesn't go and
it doesn't go a lot of other simpler
things don't go you know so something
that complex you don't want to [ __ ] it
up it's like nice it's cool
what's the simpler thing that doesn't go
very i don't know like uh
if don't mess up the recipe is what it
is right yeah kind of because they're
like oh this skewer's good at this like
but what if we add a little bit of
paprika and you're like no no don't [ __ ]
it up and that's only
that's not to say that like i'm like
that with every relationship i've had
but just in this particular one it feels
like so unique that it's like
it's it feels
more sensitive than it may even be to me
like that might just be a mirage in my
head i don't know but like the way i
look at it is like oh the parameters
it's like perfectly balanced right here
you know like a third person there's
nowhere for them to stand it's just
gonna [ __ ] it up right in the middle
balance
so um sitting on the side we have our
friend shannon she comes in as a guest
sometimes um and she she has an open
relationship with women which i thought
they had you know side
you know
play things or whatever
and but then the thing is they never
acted on it
so though i was like wait so maybe
they've been open from the start yeah
they've been it's been maybe it's kind
of like the the psychology of you want
what you can't have now that you can
have it well i don't really want it yeah
yeah i'm like so is it an open
relationship then it's not open
or you never acted on it i don't know or
maybe it's always open until
the moment is presented maybe they've
just never had that moment yeah where
it's worth it yeah but it's been many
years so i was like that's that's kind
of that is really cool yeah that is dope
what about you colleen i agree with you
really same exact across the board [ __ ]
yeah but you're not in a world i'm not
in a currency yeah but when you are
that's kind of how you always see you
guys made it sound way different in the
beginning in the beginning it's like no
this is what your significant other
really
the best way though to introduce the
threesome honestly you gotta do like
this just for all the people out there
you go like this you start
you gotta be at home first right yeah
you're like hey babe i got someone here
who are you hugging oh no no no one no
oh oh oh
but if they get [ __ ] if they get a
horn it's the tester this is the tester
that's how you test you're casting the
castle you know i know something
interesting is i had a friend um who
gets technically she
in a million years would never be the
kind of girl to say to her boyfriend
that like uh i want threesome she's
married now and um
she could never bring herself to admit
that to her husband but that's what she
wanted but she wants it in the weirdest
way where she's like i would never want
to have a reason where i even have to
address it
she said that like she wants to be
spontaneous like a happy this is her
example she said
if my husband let's say he was like
doing me from behind
and then
we're like looking out a window or
something and then in the middle of sex
she looks and notices that he's outside
walking by the window and it's really
someone else she said that would be the
hottest way to do it
wow but she doesn't even like talk about
that type of what is he doing just
watering the lawn like if you switch
with someone and then it's like surprise
it's not me and he's out there like
exactly she's in her mind that's her
fantasy but it will never happen because
she can never express that
i always thought that was really
interesting well just say the first and
last names of who it is and maybe it'll
like happen
i can't
[Music]
i mean if she's really wanting a
threesome then i guess we have to do it
huh
because she really wants to yeah i mean
if
if i got asked up for that type of thing
from
my girl now i would just you know
no that's what i mean i would just have
to do this dynamic i would just have to
disappoint her which honestly is not
that big of a deal because i could
disappoint my relationship in many ways
i think you know you know what it is is
because this isn't new to me so we spoke
about this before we even got together
officially so because the conversation
kept that it stayed that way yeah so oh
that's probably what it is it's not like
a new piece of information which is
probably shocking if your relationship
is already a certain way and then it
gets thrown on you just logistics
yeah
i've been in other relationships
i was the same way and we did talk about
it and it was something that like oh
given the right circumstances sure but
then those right circumstances are so
unique yeah it's so hard to yeah you
know unless we're like super famous rock
stars and you have like a lot of stuff
just thrown at you all day long yeah
it's hard when you name the parameters
because the [ __ ] that just does not fall
into place very easily you know
both of us never answered first no we're
just better we're at work
we're conspiring over here anytime
there's a problem never [ __ ] go first
you guys just don't know how to answer
right yeah you're right you got just
made it too real and you flip around
every time it has to end real
you